[Musique]
oui bien sûr qu'on peut faire peur mais
comment peuvent faire appel aux forces
de sécurité intérieure comme certains le
demandent actuellement il y a une règle
qui existe et que le général train quand
on connaît bien
pour ce qui est de la l'emploi des
armées sur le territoire national c'est
la fameuse règle des 4 i comme
inexistant les moyens sont inexistants
ou inexistants les moyens sont-ils
insuffisants les moyens sont-ils
inadaptée des moyens sont-ils
indisponibles ça c'est la règle qui
prévaut aujourd'hui pour déclencher par
exemple l'opération sentinelle qui a
prévalu pour déclencher l'opération
résilience voilà ça c'est le la règle à
laquelle se rattachent les armées qui
vous le savez j'ai sur un certain nombre
de fronts et non pas des moyens
extensible les armes et ses l'ultima
ratio 1 c'est ce dont on ne se sert en
dernier ressort pour la défense du pays
bien sûr mais dans deux domaines
ça peut être utilisée lorsque ça va mal
donc je reviens pas sur les quatre îles
qui viennent d'être exposé que tout le
monde connaît mais les armes et à un
moment où les choses ne fonctionnent pas
de façon optimale peuvent être appelés
mais le problème c'est dans quel dans
quel domaine il ya si vous voulez de
domaine il ya le domaine de
l'organisation ayez le domaine des
moyens
j'ai compris qu'aujourd'hui avait été
donnée quatre justice y un spécialiste
pour appuyer les services de santé dans
leur logistique
mais c'est bien un service de santé qui
est en en charge et donc les autres ne
font qu'apporter une expertise le
deuxième partie ce sont les moyens les
moyens qu'ils ont déjà été utilisés on
parle du plan résilience lors du premier
compliment mais là on peut parler aussi
du transport aux antilles de deux
congélateurs extrêmement lourds de plus
de 300 kg qui ont été emmenés par des
avions militaires parce que c'est l'été
les seuls qui pouvaient transporter ses
moyens mais en tout cas il faut bien
voir ce qu'on veut en obtenir pour
obtenir l'effet que donc vous parler
c'est à dire une accélération du
processus
si les armées sont là pour comment
dirais-je sauver le président d'un d'un
piège d'un ou d'un problème politique
et si les armées sont là pour pallier
les carences de fonctionnaires et d'un
état qui fait pas son job
à mon avis c'est pas le c'est pas la
mission désormais laser les armées ont
des moyens qui sont quels qu'ils sont et
comment dirais-je relativement limitée
est déjà engagé alors je suis d'accord
et ils ont des z'arts elles ont des
moyens qui sont spécifiques qui peuvent
permettre d'accélérer un moment donné le
processus mais si c'est pour cacher la
misère comme dit l'autre je pense que
c'est une mauvaise idée et des français
s'en rendre compte et le service de
santé des armées c'est à peu près 1% des
moyens de santé publics et privés en
france donc c'est très peu c'est
forcément symbolique
si on parle des moyens logistiques et
organisationnels alors là c'est une tout
autre affaire les armées sont des
spécialistes des experts de la
logistique de crise d'urgence
elles ont des moyens qui sont importants
et qui sont évidemment différent des
moyens civils et là effectivement il
peut y avoir un rôle pour les armées
pour je le disais tout à l'heure donnée
le le coup de booster nécessaire le coup
de fouet nécessaire pour relancer cette
campagne qui visiblement a du mal à se
déployer
vous avez rappelé simplement que les
hôpitaux des armées globalement ce sont
déjà ouverts aux civils y'a pas que les
militaires qui fera se font soigner dans
les cils illégalement donc aujourd'hui
ils sont totalement bloqués au système
qui accueille les gens qui sont
hospitalisés pour l'éco vite
le deuxième sujet c'est le sujet de la
logistique et cela vient d'être appelé
effectivement la logistique militaire a
l'habitude pourquoi parce que les armées
ont l'habitude de déployer
quand y'a plus rien une logistique pour
alimenter alimenté dans tous les
domaines a pas seulement l'alimentation
bien sûr et puis il ya le problème de
l'organisation mais je veux en venir là
aux quatre logisticiens qui ont été mis
en place
le hier je crois pour appuyer parce que
là c'est c'est une gestion des moyens
mais ça va pas être que des moyens
militaires
ça va avec des moyens aux civils donc je
voudrais revenir simplement sur le plan
de le point de la bataille ce qu'on a ce
que le président a appelé la guerre et
il ya effectivement toute façon une
bataille
à gagner dans cette vaccination et que
on veut y accélérer le processus parce
qu'on s'aperçoit que les moyens qui
avait été mis en place ne permettaient
pas d'arriver au tempo nécessaire pour
gagner la bataille et qu'on fasse appel
en complément à des moyens militaires
qu'il soit la matière grise le sien ou
des moyens ponctuelles ça me paraît
normal si les armes et interviennent en
matière de logistique
on les verra elles seront en comment
dirais-je en deuxième rideau à elles
seront pas sur le sur le elles seront
pas sur le devant de la scène d'une part
et d'autre part elles sont elles sont
clairement dans leur mission et à mon
avis les français seront tout à fait
accueilleront tout à fait cette cette
intervention avec avec beaucoup de
sympathie je pense qu'il n'y a même pas
de sujets là dessus heureux et si on
parle du des spécialistes de la santé
comme l'a dit général traquant comme
j'ai souligné tout à l'heure avec le
plan blanc les français vont déjà se
faire soigner dans les hôpitaux publics
donc je veux pour moi il n'y a pas de
sujet il ya un sujet politique je me
rappelais tout à l'heure il ya un sujet
technique mais il n'y a pas de sujet de
sur les opinions et avis non mais dans
le cas spécifique de la bataille pour la
vaccination
ça me fait aucun doute que les
renforcements d'où qu'ils viennent et
désarmé en particulier seront appréciés
par la population qui me frappe
aujourd'hui si vous voulez c'est surtout
que dès qu'il ya quelque chose qui va
pas on se tournent vers l'armée et ont
dit l'armée va être capable de régler ça
a été dans le cadre de la justice il a
été dans beaucoup de cas on en parle
alors l'armée globalement et les
plébisciter j'allais dire par la
population est naturellement quand on
l'appelle renforcement de déficiences de
vie de et c est là la population
l'applaudît donc c'est pour moi ça n'est
pas ça n'est vraiment pas un sujet